哈囉大家好 歡迎來到周慕姿放心說
我是周慕姿心理師
好 今天大家看到我穿粉紅色
因為呢 前幾天就是我們上了一個
我去韓國回來之後的一個簡單的分享
那一集我也穿粉紅色 所以被稱讚了
因此今天我就再穿個粉紅色
希望可以給大家就是讓大家感覺
氣氛比較柔和
在韓國的那一支影片
我不知道大家有沒有看到
最近就是常常有講到
就是 YouTube 有限流的一個狀況
那好像我們那個影片也遇到了限流
因為他的風格跟我之前的
不管是講心理學也好
或是講一些就是影劇的分析也好
他是比較特別跟不一樣的
因此他的觀看人數好像有點被限流了
那如果大家覺得你很想聽我分享
我去旅行或是我的一些觀察
那歡迎大家可以自己去點選
就是看看我分享我去韓國的那一集
那之後我去芬蘭的部分
我也會再分享一集給大家
最近有一件很重要的事情
這也是為什麼今天我急著
想要趕快就是錄這一集的原因
那就是在上個禮拜五
我們發生了一個蠻重大的事件
很多人的心情都有受到影響
當然也包含我們
很多時候很多人會期待
心理師在這個時候
是不是特別可以照顧大家
或是照顧自己
那麼我覺得不管是照顧大家
或照顧自己
我們要怎麼做到
讓自己的情緒平穩這件事情
是非常非常重要的
因此呢
今天我想跟大家分享這一集
就是在重大的災難或暴力事件之後
我們該如何自處
如何自我安撫
也歡迎你就是如果聽了
你覺得對你有幫助
可以分享給其他你覺得有需要的朋友
因為我最希望的就是
我們不會在這樣的焦慮底下
使得我們必須在社群平台上
不停的發出我們的焦慮
以及我們的臆測
因為在這段時間
你會看到很多人開始
會做很多的猜測
寫很多就是推理很多可能性
包含就是犯案的人
心理的可能性
還有為什麼台灣
會發生這樣的事情等等
我覺得這些事情
都不是不能討論的
但問題是
當我們現在還處在非常焦慮
甚至在這個創傷
剛剛發生的時候
我們一直去做這件事情
其實是會讓我們很緊張的
那這個緊張
為了要找到出口
我們想要把這些失控的東西
變得可以控制的東西
我們很容易用猜測
推論的方式
去讓我們得到控制感
但這些猜測跟推論
卻可能引發別人
或自己更多的恐懼
更多的焦慮
還有更多的不確定
所以今天我想要幫助大家
回到自身
讓我們看看
我們可以做些什麼
幫助自己
在這樣子的情況之下
慢慢的穩定下來
還是可以過著自己穩定的生活
但是保持謹慎
所以今天要跟大家分享的這一集
只有三個功能
第一個功能是
希望幫助大家的大腦
可以從威脅模式
回到現實模式
第二個是
希望我們可以幫助自己
跟自己的身體連結
不是說服自己沒事
第三個是
我們需要知道
我們現在這樣是正常的
而不用一直覺得自己太敏感
或是有問題
或是強迫自己沒感覺
好的
那麼首先第一個部分
是我希望大家能夠理解
我們在這一個狀態底下
當我們覺得今天出現了
一個很大的威脅
而這個威脅完全超過了
我們平常的嘗試的時候
大腦會不停的去搜尋資訊
所以他會去
很希望可以趕快去看很多資訊
能夠找到一些確定感
去幫自己確定下來
原因是因為他現在覺得
好像這件事情
會造成他沒有辦法生存
所以他會需要進入一個像
戰逃模式讓自己可以活命
於是他會開始非常的焦慮
不停的搜尋
有些人就會發現
在這段時間特別特別想要
一直看搜尋很多
在哪裡有什麼資訊
在哪裡會不會又有什麼危險
或是這個事情怎麼發生的
然後我可不可以遇到
什麼樣的跡象我要小心等等
因為很多人會發現自己
會不停的去看這些東西
這很正常
因為大腦想要找到確定的事情
讓自己放心下來
而當我們遇到非常巨大的威脅
害怕恐懼
我們沒有辦法理解的時候
焦慮感很強
就會促使我們去做這樣的事情
可是你會發現一件事
當我們越做這個事情的時候
其實我們的焦慮度會越高
甚至會發生一些替代性創傷
替代性創傷就是我們一直
暴露在這樣子的就是
不管是災難也好
或是暴力事件也好的畫面中
我們會想像我們很像是在裡面
也是經驗到這樣子的人
於是你雖然沒有經驗到這個事
你沒有在現場
但是你感受到的那一個創傷程度
有可能會跟對方可能是接近的
這件事情就有點像是替代性創傷
所以我們在這個時候
最想鼓勵大家的就是先把
就是你不停的想吸取資訊
你看重複畫面的這個習慣先停下來
因為你必須要讓你自己
不要不停的暴露在危險當中
你的大腦神經系統才可以慢下來
這件事情是很重要的
這時候就要談到大腦
有三個非常重要的預測功能
很多人可能會覺得
可是事件已經結束了
為什麼我好像還是會很害怕
我還是不停的覺得有威脅感
我還是想要去搜尋很多資訊
這有一個非常重要的點
那就是因為大腦的威脅系統
基本來說它並沒有很清楚
所謂事件結束的這一個概念
因為它主要判斷的部分有分三點
第一點就是這件事情曾經發生
第二點就是它無法預測
第三點就是它可能會再發生
當出現這三個部分的時候
大腦的威脅系統就會一直處在很警戒的狀態
因此剛剛我們說的不停的去搜尋很多資訊
想要幫助自己
不要再面對這個威脅
不要再造成這個結果
我們的大腦就沒有辦法關機的
一直去發生這樣的事情
其實這個系統它的跑法
每一次它遇到威脅的時候創傷反應
其實都是一樣的
比如說 今天我們在報告的時候
曾經被老師被主管被教授
或是被同學或是被誰羞辱
羞辱了之後
我會覺得那個羞辱感對我來說太可怕了
可怕到像我要死掉一樣
這對大腦來說是一個很重要的威脅
於是這個人
如果把這件事情變成了一個
會變成是讓它
會有反應的一個創傷反應的話
在日後它只要遇到一些別人的表情
他就會變得很緊張
比如說
當他今天要去演講的時候
他要分享什麼東西
或是要在大家面前報告的時候
他會特別留意每一個人的表情
對他來說這一些東西都是線索
而這些線索就是為了幫助他避開之前
發生這麼痛苦的事情
同樣的
所以我們大腦現在在搜尋很多資訊
就是想要幫助我們遠離這樣的痛苦
因此在這個時候
我也鼓勵大家可以感受一下你的身體
也就是說
我們大腦一直在運轉的時候
你可能以為運轉的是大腦
可是我們其實可以把注意力放回
一個很重要的東西就是我們的身體
我們身體可能會心悸
可能會身體很不舒服
可能會發抖
可能你會覺得身體很緊繃
你的肩膀、肩頸很緊繃等等
這其實都是一個
我們在一個很備戰狀態的
一個非常自然的關鍵
所以讓自己的身體可以慢慢放鬆下來
這件事情就至關重大
焦慮它是一個很有趣的
算是身心一起的一個症狀
也就是說你的情緒影響你的身體
你的身體又會再影響你的情緒
譬如說你心跳得很快
你就會很焦慮
可是你心跳慢了之後
你的焦慮度就會慢慢下降
這也就是為什麼有很多
所謂的就是讓你的心跳
變得比較慢的藥
有些人吃了之後
會覺得好像變得比較不焦慮
這其實也是同樣的道理
因為你的身體其實會影響你的心理
這是一個非常重要的關鍵
因此我們必須知道
在這個時候大腦要做的事情
不是去想通
很多人就會覺得
如果我今天那麼沒把握
不知道我就去蒐集資訊
想通一個可能性
想通一個原因
包含這個人為什麼會做這樣的事情
遇到這個事情要怎麼辦
為什麼他會長出這個樣子
我們知道一個理由
知道一個原因
我們想通之後
我們就沒事了
這個是一個非常自然的狀況
因為我們想要控制感
因為所有的不確定
都會讓我們覺得很害怕
很脆弱 很恐懼
可是在這種情況下想通是沒有用
因為你不太可能想得通
尤其是他是一個很難預測
也超越我們的經驗的事情的時候
讓我們的神經系統慢下來
才是一件最重要的事情
那怎麼讓我們慢下來呢
今天後面的部分
就是要跟大家分享這些
讓自己可以慢下來的一些方法
首先第一個技巧
是想幫助大家
從你的假設拉回的現實
現在我想請你在心裡
完成三句話
第一句話是
我現在在的地方在哪裡
第二句話是
我現在看到的三個東西
聞到的三個東西
或是碰觸到的三個東西
感受到的三個東西是什麼
第三個是
我的身體
有沒有一個比較相對放鬆的地方
那個地方是哪裡
他的感受是什麼
這三句話
其實就是幫助我們做一件事情
叫做回到當下
很多時候我們會感覺到很有威脅
很焦慮
包含像我說焦慮會出來的原因
害怕叫做什麼
我之前有一集在講 腦筋急轉2
害怕是一個我們已知的危險
而焦慮是我們想像的危險
因此威脅系統會讓我們一直假設
想像未知的未來
然後一直覺得很焦慮、很擔心
但是可以讓我們感到安全的重點
是讓我們回到當下
當下的我是安全的
當下的我是舒適的
當下的我跟這個世界 跟這個土地
跟這個人是連結的
這件事情非常重要
我也非常常在我自己
就是身體不是很舒服
或壓力很大的時候
會坐下來問問自己
我現在在哪裡
我現在是安全的
而這個時候的我
是舒適的等等
去讓自己回歸到比較安心安全的狀況
這時候也才可以做出比較好的選擇跟判斷
技巧二的重點是幫助大家
不要再回到你的思考或是你的語言
而是回到你的身體
因此很鼓勵大家可以做一些事情
幫助自己回到自己的身體
首先第一件事情鼓勵大家可以做
就是雙腳踏地的一種活動
那在這裡我分享給大家
首先是請你的雙腳踏地
然後用力三分鐘
然後放鬆
再用力三分鐘
重複二到三次
雙腳踏地不管是站著坐著都可以
其實就是幫助你可以感覺到
你的身體是可以跟這個地板
跟這個世界是有連結的
但最主要其實是幫助你回到你的身體
當然在這裡也有些人會發現
可是我好像一直都很緊張
我的呼吸很淺
那麼我就會很推薦你
四七八呼吸法
所謂四七八呼吸法
就是一般的放鬆呼吸法
吸氣四秒
然後憋氣七秒
然後放鬆八秒
雖然說是秒啦
但是其實我覺得不用到
就是大家就是要用手錶讀秒
這麼嚴格
因為這個東西就會讓你又沒有辦法放鬆
你可以從心裡數到四
數到七
數到八
這樣就可以
我會很鼓勵大家平常覺得壓力很大
或是你覺得你的呼吸
很淺的時候 你就可以做這件事
因為這件事情
它可以讓你的身體 會變得放鬆
可是呢
你突然做是不會放鬆的
常常做你的身體習慣之後
你一做這個動作
你的身體就知道 我可以放鬆了
這一件事情
慢慢的讓你的身體
訓練出一個規律
是一件蠻重要的事情
最後 我也想跟大家分享一個
這個有很多名詞
我自己最常就是就叫它 蝴蝶抱
之前有一部韓劇
《雖然是精神病但沒關係》
裡面就有這個蝴蝶抱
也就是說把你的雙手
交叉放在你的胸前
然後呢
可以眼睛閉上
然後輕輕的拍拍自己
拍拍自己可以告訴自己
我現在是安全的
我是舒服的
我可以放心
沒有關係的
就算我現在緊張 也是正常的
我是可以保護自己的
你可以在用這樣的方式
讓你的心跟你的狀態
慢慢的穩定下來
而這個輕輕的拍打
其實都是一個很快速的
可以幫助我們 自我安撫的小技巧
其他包含我很鼓勵大家
可以去
在你覺得你的情緒狀況
不是很穩定的時候
喝一杯水
或是喝熱飲
喝熱茶
就是有一個溫度的變化
以及讓你自己 可以去跟人擁抱
擁抱自己也可以
就是例如說 你家裡有小抱偶
然後你可以就是小玩偶
你可以抱它
然後也感覺你自己被擁抱
或是有些人會 家裡有擁抱毯
那也是很好的東西
以及你跟他人也可以
就是跟你的好友
跟你的家人
你可以有擁抱
你的寵物等等
這些接觸都會增加你的
就是不管是有些人說
血清素也好
或是讓你的情緒
還有你的神經系統 變得比較平穩
它是一個非常非常
幫助我們的心
慢慢穩定下來的方式
再來 還有一個最後的提醒
那就是我想鼓勵大家
盡可能 維持正常的生活
有些人會因為這樣子
就會盡可能 想要避開
發生事情的地方
或是 我是不是就不要搭捷運了
或者是我不要去車站等等
會想要避開
我想這些避開都是有道理的
如果你覺得接近本身
都會讓你覺得很不舒服
你想避開也是很正常的
但如果你還可以忍受
我會相對的比較鼓勵你
盡可能在你的日常生活中
維持你原本的步調
原因是因為
當我們因為害怕
而避開一些事情的時候
我們到最後就會
越來越限縮我們的範圍
我們就會越來越害怕這件事情
但如果今天我們告訴自己
沒關係我會去注意
而且其實旁邊的人也會注意
我們可能大家
都在注意這件事情
於是我 還是可以盡可能
比較讓自己維持
原本的生活步調
你會去做完這件事情之後
就覺得其實還好
沒有我想像中的那麼嚴重
生活還是有蠻多
可靠的 跟安全的地方
這些東西 會慢慢恢復你的安全感
因此我會蠻鼓勵你
不管是出門也好
或是你的生活也好
盡可能維持同樣的步調
最後 最後提醒大家
如果你發現了
你的狀況並不是很好
那什麼情況 需要專業的協助呢
首先你發現了就是
你出現很明顯的
失眠或是做惡夢
然後甚至影響你的生活功能
超過一兩個禮拜以上
特別是兩個禮拜以上
當然現在事情剛發生
都還沒有出現這個狀況
可是 因為我們之前
也有很多類似的
就是大型的災難
或是還有一些其他事情
如果你發現你有失眠
或是做惡夢等等 超過兩週
而且你會一直出現反覆的一些
侵入性的畫面
比如說 你可能你是在現場
或者是
你有看到的這些新聞畫面
然後你的腦中
就一直出現那個畫面
讓你的生活沒有辦法維持正常的
就是作息 功能等等
甚至讓你覺得你 過度警覺
每次要出門的時候
你都好緊張冒冷汗
甚至你會覺得出去
要去搭捷運什麼的
你根本沒有辦法
你會發抖等等
這個狀況 我就會非常鼓勵你
請就是尋找專業的協助
這倒不是說因為我們
就是好像很脆弱 怎麼會這樣
這可能代表著
你的大腦警覺系統
它真的是特別特別的敏感
所以它覺得這個威脅很大
它很想要保護你
因此它過度警覺
你可以想像一下
你的那個警報系統
就是它有點過敏感
有人經過它就一直
嗶嗶嗶嗶嗶嗶叫
甚至有些人可能是因為之前
有經驗過類似的事情
所以這樣的事件
可能又會再勾起它的創傷記憶
或是讓它很不舒服
這個時候尋求專業協助
是一個非常正確的做法
也鼓勵跟分享給大家
在這一段時間
我覺得 對大家都不是很容易
可是我在想
我們可能都還是可以
為這個社會做一點點事情
那一點點事情 可能包含了
當我們願意
給彼此一點支持
彼此一點安慰
給自己的心 一點點安全感
還有我們不要花太多時間
去臆測、去猜測或是去就責
因為在這樣的過程中
常常可能都會
離事實比較遙遠
所有的事情它都有會被
知道真相的一天
而我們現在最重要的事情
其實是把
我們的心安頓下來
今天十分鐘心理學
跟大家分享的這個部分
希望對大家能夠有一些幫助
而今天分享的很多
就是自我安撫的一些技巧
不僅僅是在
重大事件發生可以做
在我們遇到過度焦慮
會讓我們覺得很威脅
很恐懼的事情
都可以用來
安定我們的身心
希望大家可以試試看
也許對你會有一些幫助哦
如果大家喜歡我們的話
歡迎大家按讚分享
開啟小鈴鐺
如果是Podcast的朋友
也歡迎就是給我們五星好評
那每一個留言我都會看
所以今天剛好是聖誕節
希望大家有一個
美好的聖誕節
以及新年快樂
好的 那麼周慕姿放心說
我們下次見囉
拜拜